ما ذكرت لي الفحوى الطلب
سالتها قلت لها هذا يعني رساله من
البنتاغون من اي جهه قالت لي من كل الجهات
يعني من البنتاغون من سيايايين من
بيت الابيض من كل متفقين اصحاب القرار
متفقين على رساله يكتب خطيده تطلع انت
بالاعلام تقراها مقابل هذا طبعا يطلب من
القوات
نعم
مقابل هذا يخرج الى احد ثلاث عواصم عربيه
اخترناها واتفقنا معاه هذه العواصم الاردن
مصر دول نعم نعم مصر قطر الاردن مصر قطر
مصر قطر عرضوا عليك عرض شخصي لالك نعم
وايضا اني اذا اقنعته
ممكن يعني اكون معها يعني اخرج انا
وعائلتي
وجيبي متصل مثل ما يعني حكوا جيب متصل
بالخزنه العراقيه وما عندي مشكله واي واحد
يريدها
اي واحد يريد الرئيس يخرج معه يخرج لكن
يعتزل عمل سياسي بشكل نهائي والعمل
الاعلامي
اكدت مره ثانيه
مثلا اغراءات اخرى نعم وعرض اخر انه اذا
يعني اقتنع الرئيس اقنعت الرئيس يعني ممكن
يكون يعني يختار اي شخص اخر ونفضل ان تكون
انت يختارك في العمل السياسي نقدر نوصلك
احنا الى مستوى نائب رئيس جمهوريه نعم
مقابل ان تقنع قلت لهم اني يعني هذا الطلب
مالكم اوصله ويبقى الخيار اله بتفاصيل هل
ذكرت شيئا لك عن طبيعه المحاكمه عن المساك
نعم كانت تاكد على قالت لي اني من باب
النصيحه الطريق اللي ماشي بيه انت يا
استاذ خليل ما يوصلك للهدف اللي انت تبغيه
اللي هو الطريق القانوني طريق القانوني
نعم طريق معطل والمحاكمه نوهت انه راح
تكون صوريه ونتيجتها معروفه الاعدام